sur les lignes
aériennes c'est comme sur les
autoroutes quand on se fait accuser de
toute part c'est sans doute que on est
dans le juste milieu donc on nous
reproche de fermer des lignes on nous
reproche de ne pas enfermer c'est pas
une décision de l'État a France est une
entreprise dont l'état est actionnaire
mais pas actionnaire majoritaire je vais
être très direct avec vous je regrette
la méthode qui a été trop rapide et qui
aurait mérité une discussion approfondie
avec les élus concernés de la desur ou
d'ailleurs puisque la ville de Toulouse
est concernée par exemple euh vous
l'avez cité implicitement à la fois la
liaison pour Marseille et pour Nice euh
mais c'est un une étape de travail qu'ir
France a annoncé j'insiste sur ce point
j'ai demandé et la direction d'Air
France est très engagé à ce qu'il y a
une discussion avec les élus locaux
d'ailleurs Renaud Muselier Caro delgat
plusieurs autres Christian estrosil
l'ont indiqué pour que la desserte
puisque c'est ça qui compte le plus soit
assuré au bon niveau y compris au-delà
de 2026 qui est l'horizon du plan
annoncé par Air France via notamment
Transavia donc c'est une discussion qui
commence ce n'est pas la fin de
l'histoire et l'entreprise est attachée
les élus plus encore et c'est légitime à
la qualité d'une desserte économiquement
indispensable touristiquement
indispensable vers Paris je suivrai ce
travaux de très près vous avez sans
loute vu les communiqués récents
notamment du président Muselier qui
montre que ce travail de concertation il
aura peut-être dû être fait différemment
se traduit aujourd'hui par des réunions
euh dans les prochains jours